there have been Security Council
meetings on Ukraine before but this is
by far the highest level meeting since
the War Began
the latest developments are dangerous
and disturbing they are further steps
away from any Prospect of peace and
towards an endless cycle of horror and
bloodshed
as a permanent member of the council
Russia has previously vetoed any efforts
to denounce its attack on Ukraine and in
reality there's little the council can
do to stop the fighting one man chose
this war
one man can end it
because if Russia stops fighting
the war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting
Ukraine ends
Russian foreign minister Sergey lavrov
only appeared in the chamber just
moments before his turn to speak he
insisted what the Russians call the
special military operation was
inevitable after the 2014 revolution in
Ukraine
there is an attempt today to impose on
us a completely different narrative
about Russian aggression as the origin
of the tragedy this ignores the fact
that for over eight years Ukrainian Army
and fighters from the Nationalist groups
killed and continue to kill inhabitants
of dunbas with impunity simply because
they've refused to recognize the result
of the coup d'etat in Kiev when he
finished his remarks the Russian
Diplomat left something the British did
not ignore his left the chamber
I'm not surprised I don't think Mr
lavrov wants to hear
the collective condemnation of this
Council and Ukraine's foreign minister
didn't let the moment pass either I also
noted today that Russian diplomats flee
almost as aptly as Russian soldiers he
called for peace he called for support
and he had this warning for Russia
yesterday Putin announced mobilization
but what he really announced before the
whole world was his defeat
you can draft 300 500 000 people
that you will never win this war the
meeting was called to discuss alleged
abuses and atrocities in Ukraine the
international criminal court announced
its own investigation in March and the
chief prosecutor told the council that
while no one has been charged yet there
is growing evidence that war crimes have
been committed Alan Fisher Al Jazeera at
the United Nations in New York